well thanks everyone as mentioned I'm
Kelly tack the National Sales Director
at nucleus and thank you very much for
staying through here for the last
presentation on the last day I'm
certainly going to try and make it worth
your while and you know okay
Tony if you would so today
[Music]
[Applause]
as you can see okay so nucleus this year
I celebrated its 20th year anniversary
of being in business and we are one of
the leading creators of 3d medical
animations and illustrations for
hospitals and their agencies and we're
one of the largest employers of graduate
degree medical illustrators in the world
and I stress graduate degree there
meaning that after they've done their
undergraduate they actually go on to
additional four years of schooling
sitting side by side with the soon-to-be
doctors working on cadavers taking gross
anatomy physiology biology and reason
why that's important is there's
certainly a lot of talented artists out
there but the experience that they have
the detailed understanding that they
have of the science and of the body
really was what differentiates their
content when they develop it okay so
over 1,500 hospitals in the u.s. used
some form of nucleus content right now
whether it be on their website or in
social media or even at point of care
and our word wedding content it's
considered the gold standard in the
industry just because as I mentioned the
level of detail the accuracy the
cinematic quality and also the ability
to attract viewers we also work with
some very familiar brands in education
and media as you can see some some big
publishing companies some big education
some some big budget websites but the
key thing is that you can utilize the
same level of high quality content for
your own websites to attract more
viewers okay so how many of you have a
youtube channel currently everybody I
would assume at this point right okay
great so that's really again what I want
to focus on mainly today and a recent
study by Google showed that YouTube is
highly effective at driving traffic and
I wouldn't say I started it on
presentation one of the conference's
last year or the Google representative
spoke and said that more and more people
when searching for healthcare related
topics are going right to YouTube
they're even bypassing Google now
because who wants to read is the general
consensus if you can find a video on a
related topic they're actually beginning
their search on YouTube
and YouTube is really it's proven to
shown that they're converting people to
your websites were they're much more
likely to book an appointment and the
same study showed that most patients
begin their journey by searching online
just for diseases and conditions and
symptoms you know so there's really
starting for general information and
then you know they want to find that out
first and then they're looking at about
a place for treatment afterwards so
having a YouTube channel with general
information helps you to reach patients
in that early stage of their journey in
that discovery stage and then helps them
to drive them to your website where they
can be converted into appointments ok so
what is the YouTube now what does
nucleus know about YouTube so I honestly
I've been with the company a little over
3 years now and this was a surprising
statistic for me when I first joined
here we launched our channel in 2007 so
it's now 10 years and we have going to
be the number one medical animation
channel on YouTube
we have over 300 million views and
almost 600 thousand subscribers and just
a quick look at some of our own
analytics is the 30 day graph that shows
we average over 110 thousand views per
day nearly 4 million views per month and
we add about 16,000 new subscribers each
month so it's our number one lead
generator and honestly the same
principles can apply for you as well so
people ask your why animations we
certainly have heard a lot about live
video but why animations and not just
live video and really the honest answer
to that is the animations perform much
better than plain live videos on the
same subjects because the content is
more attractive it's easier to
understand it's not bloody it's not gory
I mean I've still shocked at times and
I've heard some of you I'm sure I've
heard the same stories surgeons want you
to post their actual live footage and
you know the idea is you're trying to
reduce anxiety and the patient's not
generate more anxiety innovation so you
know showing off your handiwork
peer-to-peer that's great patients don't
want to see that so that doesn't mean
the video has to be a hundred percent
animation though honestly some of the
most effective ones are that use a
combination of your own live footage and
the medical animations
and this is just a brief look at you
know our animations do perform better
than any of our competitors out there as
far and subscribers so if you're going
to utilize animations certainly we would
say you the ones that are the most
proven to be the most effective and
honestly you don't need to have
thousands or even hundreds of videos in
order to generate significant traffic
better strategies to do fewer higher
quality content videos that are relevant
to your specific target markets and the
areas that you're looking to reach so
for example you know if you're looking
to reach more patients in cardiology or
orthopedics or pediatrics or women's
health so you want to have in post
videos that are related to those
specific areas I mean you know best what
are the areas that you're looking to
target so focus specifically on those
areas to begin with and certainly
alright so the fastest and honestly
cheapest way for putting animations to
use is to utilize our stock animation
and we do have an ever-expanding library
of stock animations that you're
available to use and what you can do
with these is you can really pre roll I
mean as simple as pre rolling in your
brand your logo your introduction and
then you can post it right away on
YouTube or on your website now a common
question that we get asked a lot is well
how do I stand apart on youtube if I'm
going to use your stock animations when
maybe my competitor is going to be using
stock animation - right fair question
certainly and then really again the most
effective way to do that is to
incorporate it with your own video
footage again not only branding and logo
and call to actions but with your own
physicians with your own patients you
know with their own stories so I'm going
to show you some examples about some of
our clients
they were giving me a cat scan test cat
scan after seeing that my mighty order
was enlarged we cut out the ACM in order
we cut out up to the aortic arch and
sometimes you'll have to replace the
earth guards and we replace it with a
polyester material called a cron we
often recommend robotic bypass surgery
for our patients we have diabetes and
other severe ailments of severe obesity
if you suffer from severe obesity and
have been unable to lose weight we may
recommend robotic gastric bypass surgery
ready that's so me that's traffic after
pageant
now we're getting there I've always had
a really active lifestyle growing up I
was a three-sport athlete and then I
went on to college and I played college
basketball my name is Andy Wallace and I
came to Penn medicine due to severe
urinary incontinence the patient first
comes in to talk about their
incontinence I usually want to gauge how
much it's bothering them and how much
they're willing to do to change the
problem the autologous sling uses a
small bikini incision to harvest fashio
which lines all of our muscles to be
used as the sling this sling has been
placed to support the urethra in a very
similar fashion to the way mesh is used
and that helps to prevent urinary
leakage so those threes example showed
three different ways that the content
can be utilized within your own footage
for example two so the first one I'd say
that entire video which might have been
a with the Marfan syndrome patient had
about twenty seconds of our animation in
it so they talked to the patient he
explaining what was his situation they
talked to his doctor what they were
going to do and then they just used the
animation part of it really to again to
give that level of education the robotic
surgery doctor they actually utilized
our entire video and that had him do the
introduction which you saw they removed
our narration and had their own
physician do the voice-over so he
actually you know he spoke through
the entire video explaining what you
were seeing and then they had a closing
call-to-action for it and then the third
example as you could tell was a much
more highly produced type of video where
again they only use you know they talked
about the patient what she in
experiencing they talked with her
physician about what the procedure and
how it was going to give her some relief
and use about 15 seconds of animation
and that's all but it really does make a
difference in the in the viewership that
you'll receive so another way to work
with us is to Commission nucleus to
create a custom animation which is an
exclusive production that's created to
your specifications so the script
development the storyboard development
everything is done in review with your
team your your clinicians review in a
day weigh in on it what are the key
learning objectives what are the key
visual objects so that can be done you
know in concert with your team and so
you know why why the patient why are
some hospitals willing to pay more for a
custom animation and really it gets back
to defer annotation on your treatment on
your physicians on your services and
sometimes to reach a far larger patient
base so for example some of the stills
that you see here we're done with the
norm and parathyroid Center and the
video that they posted on YouTube has
now been translated into seven different
languages and they actually attract
patients from all around the world to
their to their facility in Florida so
I'm going to roll you some examples of
some custom work that we've done as well
to if your baby has hypoplastic left
heart syndrome your doctor may recommend
the hybrid stage one approach
the hybrid stage one is the first of
three minimally invasive procedures
designed to lower the risks associated
with traditional open-heart surgery the
goal of the hybrid stage one is to
improve the blood flow in your baby's
body the procedure is usually performed
within the first week of life the
combined surgical and interventional
cardiology teams will perform the hybrid
stage one procedure there are four
parathyroid glands located behind the
thyroid gland parathyroid glands monitor
and control the amount of calcium in our
blood and bones by secreting a hormone
called parathyroid hormone or PTH each
gland monitors the blood calcium and
responds by making more or less PTH
hormone hyperparathyroidism is a disease
that occurs when one of the parathyroid
glands develops a tumor this tumor
produces far too much parathyroid
hormone which is released into the
bloodstream
if a person has epilepsy some neurons
may fire too rapidly and randomly send
many messages at the same time this
overwhelms the brain and causes seizures
to reduce or stop seizures a pediatric
neurosurgeon may perform a two-part
surgery the surgeon will place a grid
with electrodes on to the brain the
electrodes will stay on the brain until
the second surgery so again these are
some different examples as to the
execution as to why people would want a
custom animation for the first example
Nationwide Children's Hospital the
procedure that we worked on with and I
actually are continuing to work with
them on is a unique proprietary
procedure to them it's a new technique
that they've developed that they really
wanted to have to explain and that
they're going to actually you know use
for professional purposes as well and
parents so you can create something new
with us that is very specific to you if
it's unique and proprietary or if it's a
matter of you have something that you're
very focused on that we don't have a
current stock animation for that can be
developed you know as an example there's
a system we work with in Baltimore that
had just acquired a large orthopedic
practice and they had a lot of foot and
ankle specialist and so they were
looking for some things on ankle fusion
and some other techniques that we didn't
currently have so we worked in
conjunction with them to develop them
again their review of the script their
review of the storyboard exactly how
they wanted to have it said and what was
said they then gained you know extended
year use of that video but the the idea
behind it is we were able to have a
lower upfront cost because that's
something that's not unique and
proprietary to them people do ankle
fusion obviously all in the country so
we're able to add that back into our
library so I refer to that as like a
sponsoring cost you can have it directly
done to your specifications and have
extended year use of it we're going to
have a lower rate to create that product
because we know there's the opportunity
for us as a licensure of content for
recurring revenue so if we add that into
our library there's other facilities
around the country that would make use
of that content as well so we're willing
to forego the upfront cost knowing that
we can we can get it on the back end for
again for something that's truly custom
and that no one else would use it's a
little bit of a different price point so
it's
move on so YouTube tactics so it's not
just enough to post them on YouTube
there are still some things that you and
your creative team can do to make them
even that much more popular so let's
start with the metadata and like the
title the descriptions of tags so load
those up with not only the names and the
diseases of the conditions themselves
but also common acronyms that are used
to so P pH or afib or cabbage you know
some consumers out there are savvy
enough to know those are the common
terminology so use those as well too so
make sure that the patients are able to
find them there but be careful not to
use too many keywords in the title or it
reduces your keyword density but there
is the caveat that if you want to pick
up traffic from a very specific
geographical region or a particular
practice or specialty then you can then
you can definitely add that as well too
and for conversions be sure to add link
backs you know just a link in your
hospitals website as you can see don't
forget the inhale so as you can see the
link back to nucleus for us but link
that back in the description so again
just makes it that much easier for them
to come back to your facility and also
use an annotated link at the end screen
so for us that little baby head that you
see there if you were if you were to
click on that takes you back to the
nucleus site and one of the things that
we found too is that viewers
consistently click on animation still
more often than just a photograph so as
you can see some of the examples here
it's the exact same topic but if you
look at the stills that they're showing
the photographic stills because it's all
live footage versus the the photograph
of the animation and the views are
significantly higher and I think that's
just become commonplace for most
patients when they're given an option to
see the kind of a you know perhaps the
procedure room or just a talking head of
the doctor versus an animation they do
tend to click on the animation much more
frequently and then you want to think
about yourself as almost like you're
launching a TV station where you want to
produce new content on a regular basis
so maybe you start out with once a week
and then you move out to twice a month
but and then you get up to once a month
and you're organically growing more
subscribers over time that way too
people understand if they're looking for
content the more you continue to post
fresh content the more they see that it
is relevant it's a channel that's being
attended to and that they know they can
come back
and find continue to find more good
content and but lastly if it's not
performing well tweak some things I mean
it's all in experiment I mean sometimes
slow moving you know slow viewership on
videos just changing a title or an image
can really make a difference it can make
them things take off so what are the
experiences that we've had with some of
our custer's doing this and most see
those that use these are the YouTube
channels of some of our clients they see
the animation of the videos with
animations they tend to organically rise
to the top percentage of all that
they're all of their YouTube videos and
you can see some more examples here they
tend to rise up always to be some of the
most viewed so looking back why's
nucleus a great partner for you so our
experience as the leading channel
medical animations on YouTube means we
have the content and the skill set the
ability to help you have a high
performing channel as well
and your more YouTube traffic ultimately
results in more website traffic for you
which ultimately we hope links to more
appointments and conversions for you as
well - and as just mentioned more
appointments there - so price what does
it cost common question I get it all the
time as you would suspect so stock
innovations not going to be much
different if any of you use any
subscription services getting any kind
of rights managed license services out
there and it really depends upon how
much content you're using the more
content you use the lower the price
point comes down how many facilities you
know some of you if you have more than
one location whether it be hospitals the
amount of clinics or the amount of
practices how much are you using it you
can amortize that cost out over the over
the different facilities and custom
animation it is based on the complexity
of it that definitely requires a
discovery call you know with you with
your your leading subject matter expert
determine what is the scope what is the
amount of research that needs to be done
by our team and in the writing and in
the development stage and then what is
the production time but even then we
still do produce things at lower than
the average cost and the reason for that
is we really want to find you know this
is a large market that really hasn't
still slowly embracing let's say the use
of animation and we know from experience
if people will start out by using just
one with us and say hey you know what
that really got great results or how
many of you
you know find that you do one particular
initiative for service line with the
other service lines all say right
where's mine
why can't I have that as well too so
we're happy to get things in your hands
at a low cost because we know it's going
to organically grow your relationship
with us over time as well so my last
video clip here I'm going to show you
some examples of testimonials some of
our clients and physicians that have
utilized our animations and the
experience that they've had with it we
can tell that we're increasing the
number of patients that we're seeing on
a daily basis and we're getting fewer
callbacks so the nursing staff is being
much more helpful with seeing patients
that are in the office rather than
spending time on the phone but by and
large the patients come in they have
fewer questions we don't have the
callbacks much better educated on
exactly what's going to be done
surgically and for the non surgical
patients they have a much better
understanding of why we're having to
protect them why they're wearing a brace
why they're doing the rehab so overall
it's been a much better patient
education and from a physician's point
of view I think we're getting better
results because the patient's truly
understand what's going on if you add
from a surgical standpoint if you add
the amount of money to the video calls
per year versus the amount of patients
that you see because you become more
effective and more efficient I would say
the videos probably pay for yourself
- its impatient the end result is a
beautiful animation that's been viewed
many millions of times in seven
languages so we really are accomplishing
our goal which is to teach the world
about this disease we're reaching many
people who have nothing to do with our
practice we're just we're just enhancing
the education of patients and doctors
worldwide I've enjoyed all of my
interactions with nucleous medical
they've been insightful
they've been very timely in their
efforts when we you know obviously
there's iterations and development of
these animations and every time that we
came back to them they were receptive to
our reviews and really sort of
intellectualize those comments and then
put them into action into making this
even better than we could have imagined
so the first thing I'll say about that
that really is that doctor's office that
wasn't our camera he does have purple
bookshelves in his office so that's not
just a video but really I mean the point
there is you know the point there is
that the physicians like it because
we've heard on many occasions them say
you know I say the same thing over and
over 20 30 times a day when I'm visiting
patients and the nursing staff will say
you know when we bring someone in if I'm
able to sit them down and watch and have
them watch a video I'm able to move and
do other things and then come back to
them the doctors have said that they say
between five to seven minutes per
patient
just because they've established that
baseline of knowledge and had some of
their basic questions answered before
they talk with the doctor so you know
five to seven minutes doesn't sound like
a lot but if you think about that per
day per week per month per year that
gives them a lot of time back and that
time could be spent either seeing
additional patients or for those you
know certain patients that do require
more time spent with them they have that
and that's really critical to them as
well and even in some of the larger
systems that we work with you know
there's always the in Turkey talking
with the nursing staff they were very
frank and honest about it and they'll
say you know sometimes I'll leave out of
talking with the patients afterwards
I'll say oh I forgot to mention that I
should I should have told her that or
there'll be you know nurses on the same
floor that explain things in different
ways they might just use a little
different language or just or different
terminology and the idea of using a
video is it's consistency the same
message is given to every patient
there's never any question about did
they hear this and again it's told in
the same manner so the you know the the
not only the end result of the patient
being a better-educated which enables
them to understand their condition
better and maybe manage their own
self-care better and which wouldn't we
would hope to lead to better outcomes
and also again the ability to be
confident that okay I know what this
procedure has in store for me I've seen
it I know it you know my doctors told me
it's going to know it's going to be fine
and they gain the confidence to go ahead
and move forward with that procedure so
any questions no all right
yes all right well thanks very much my
contact info is there please feel free
to reach out to me at any time
any questions be happy to send you some
information links to review our content
and thanks again appreciate you being
here on the last day Scott thank you I
hope to talk to you all again soon thank
you very much
[Applause]